[Music]
I met more people who essentially
somewhere along the way picked up you go
to school you get trained in something
then you go get a job in that and then
you do that job and that's your career
and then you die but then they got into
this thing and realized they don't
actually want to do this with their life
or nobody wants this particular trade
anymore
you make 8-track players people aren't
buying eight tracks anymore there's this
weird thing about the market where if
you go in with well this is a thing that
I do there may be forces beyond you that
like no one wants to pay for that
anymore and so what over the years I
kept meeting people who had this very
single track this is what I'm supposed
to do thing and then it disappointed
them for reasons out of their control or
simply I got trained to do this thing I
don't like to do then I stumbled on this
Japanese word a key guy and the key guy
essentially is that which gets you out
of bed in the morning and sometimes
that's translated your reason for being
and in Japanese culture they have this
very well thought through idea of a key
guy that you never stop working out
you're a key guy what it is that gets
you out of bed in the morning and so in
this season of life this is what you're
doing
but that may change it may shift
somebody you love may get sick and so
you need to care for them you used to do
this and now that industry is sort of
dried up but now you need to go back to
school because you need to now go do
this and I had this really interesting
idea that when you no longer have
something that gets you out of bed in
the morning then you're kind of dead
even if you're still alive
and the reason why I find that
fascinating is you can be successful you
can have a nice job you can have a nice
house you can do all the stuff that
everybody says hey you've made it and
yet wake up in the morning with a
profound sense of dread like another day
and despair despair as a spiritual
disease despair is when you believe
that tomorrow will simply be a repeat of
today despair is when you look ahead
into the future and each day is just
another version of this what we really
want no matter how educated
sophisticated accomplished we are we
want to wake up in the morning with this
sense of anticipation like look what I
get to do today the great Abraham Joshua
Heschel said I didn't ask for a success
I asked for wonder and I love that
because for many of us we were trained
for success we were trained here's how
you work hard and multitask and network
and get stuff done and climb the ladder
what we weren't taught oftentimes was to
ask is this ladder even leaned up
against the right building which is a
different set of questions it's like it
exerts a different set of muscles it's
one thing to be successful it's another
thing to wake up and think check out
what I get to do today how great is this
it's as if success asks this question
what more can I get and then there's
this other question very different that
comes out of a key guy understanding
your life as a craft that you're
endlessly sort of working out there's
another question which is can you
believe I get to do this
[Music]
it's like you have this thing that's
been sort of buzzing in your mind and
heart like I would love to go try that
but then all those voices come back in
of who you aren't you aren't you don't
know for resources you're not smart
enough you haven't gone to the right
schools by the way who you aren't isn't
interesting long lists of things you
haven't done or where you haven't been
or who you don't know or money you don't
have it's so boring
who you aren't isn't interesting and
then when you are finding your path when
you are saying yes to whatever it is
that's sort of welling up within you
that is feeling you with filling you
with a sense of wonder and anticipation
who other people are in relation to your
path isn't interesting because often
what happens is we think I would do that
but selling so smarter and so-and-so's
faster and so and so has more endurance
and can work harder and so and so always
gets not interesting it's not
interesting you finding your path the
only question is what is the thing that
you're here to do and what is the next
step and fear often raises its voice and
fear lists all the ways it can go wrong
and by the way the best thing with fear
is to talk back to fear because fear
like fears like you could lose a lot of
money people might not understand this I
mean you might really fail and the thing
you do with fear is talk back to fear
because fear thinks it's quite
intelligent it's like I'm here to warn
you of all the bad things that could
happen and you probably haven't thought
of this and this and this and here's the
thing you do is you talk to fear and you
say to fear whenever fear suck you know
what this could really really be a giant
catastrophe this could be a mess you
could really fail what you say to fear
is you say to fear I know and then you
smile I know I know because fear has no
idea what to do with that I'm aware of
all that life is difficult enough you
might as well be doing something that
fills you with life it's going to beat
you up enough you might as well be
getting up in the morning with some
sense of I'm headed somewhere I'm I'm
I'm a step closer to being my true self
today
and you know you're making progress when
all those voices come and say who are
you to do this who do you think you are
you know you're making progress when you
start talking back to those voices and
you have an even better question which
is Who am I not to do this there will
always be somebody smarter there will
always be somebody who knows more people
there will always be somebody who's
traveled to more places and got better
grades in school and has more money
there will always be somebody better but
you can say but Who am I not to do this
and that's that that's interesting
[Music]